if you traveled
10 000 years into the future what
would planet earth look like
would most of its surface be covered in
volcanoes
or would it be frozen in ice
what if you traveled even further to
one million years in the future would
all of the oceans have evaporated or
would it have become one giant water
world
okay now what about 1 billion years
would there be any humans left
or would they have settled in other
parts of the galaxy
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you traveled 1 billion years into the
future
let's face it the chances of any humans
being around to greet you when you
arrive 1 billion years into the future
are
pretty low several
key existential threats face the human
race and
if we want to be around in one billion
years we'll need to endure them all
we've seen how much we've struggled to
come together just to survive a global
pandemic
so how do we have any chance of enduring
the threats of climate change
overpopulation global nuclear war killer
asteroids and comets natural ice ages
and
the sun getting a whole lot hotter
well let's take a look into the future
and find out
just under ten thousand years from now
we're going to run into a
big problem called the deca millennium
bug
in the year ten thousand ad software
encoding the ad calendar year
won't encode dates with more than four
decimals
remember y2k yeah it's just like that
except hopefully we won't panic as much
this time around
on the bright side in 10 000 years
genetic differences and traits between
humans
will no longer be regional traits like
skin and hair color
will be evenly distributed around the
world
maybe that will help us all get along
finally
twenty thousand years into the future
none of the current languages will be
recognizable
future languages will only contain one
percent of the core vocabulary words of
their
present day counterparts fifty thousand
years from now
will mark a new glacial period for the
earth
which will start a new ice age
niagara falls will have eroded into lake
erie completely
and interestingly a full day on earth
will also
increase by one second at this point in
time
so much more time for activities
in 250 000 years the loihi volcano
will rise above the water to form a new
island in hawaii
and in 500 000 years it's likely that
an asteroid with a diameter greater than
one kilometer will hit
earth unless we can prevent it
the resulting crater will be no less
than 400 kilometers across
it will start fires all over the planet
and make the air
unbreathable so there's something to
look forward to
and in case that's not enough in 1
million years
we'll likely have another super volcano
eruption
large enough to spew out 3 200 cubic
kilometers of ash
it would produce enough lava to fill 75
of the grand canyon this would be
similar to the toba eruption that
almost wiped out humanity 70 000 years
ago
oh and the nearby star beetlejuice
will have exploded into a supernova by
this time
making it visible from earth even during
the daytime
in 2 million a.d humanity will have
settlements throughout the solar system
this also means that if populations on
different planets have remained separate
humans may have evolved into other
species
adapted to their specific world
in 10 million years a huge part of
eastern africa will break off
forming a new ocean basin
[Music]
in 50 million years africa will collide
with
eurasia closing off the mediterranean
sea
and a new mountain range will form
between the two land masses
this mountain range may include a
mountain taller than mount everest
out in space mars will collide with its
moon
resulting in it developing a ring system
like saturn's
in 60 million years the canadian and
american rockies
will have eroded entirely
[Music]
in 80 million years all hawaiian islands
will be below the water
[Music]
in 100 million years an asteroid similar
to the one that killed the dinosaurs
66 million years ago will likely hit
earth
one that is 10 kilometers wide
in 250 million years all of earth's
continents will be
fused together like pangaea except this
time
it will be called pangaea ultima but
don't get too attached to it because in
400 to 500 million years
pangaea ultima will separate again
in 500 to 600 million years a gamma ray
burst will likely occur
within 6 500 light years from earth
if it strikes earth it could damage the
ozone layer
and trigger a mass extinction
600 million years from now the moon will
be so far from earth
that total solar eclipses will no longer
be possible
and the sun's increasing luminosity will
have raised temperatures
on earth so much that it could halt
plate tectonics movement
in 800 million years carbon dioxide
levels will drop
dramatically and photosynthesis will no
longer be possible
free oxygen and ozone will disappear
from the atmosphere
and complex life on earth will die
and finally in 1 billion years
the sun's luminosity will have increased
by 10 percent
and the average temperature on earth
will be 47 degrees celsius
our atmosphere will feel like a damp
greenhouse and
our oceans will evaporate leaving just
pockets of water at each of the poles
[Music]
when you arrive here in your time
machine
be mentally prepared to take in a planet
earth that looks
nothing like the one you remember
the human race will be gone
hopefully living its best life on some
other far-off planet
because of the intense heat lack of
water and
lack of breathable air earth will be
uninhabitable
so you probably shouldn't stay too low
instead
you should head out to see the rest of
the solar system
maybe you'll find your fellow humans
there or
some other form of intelligent life but
that's a story
for another what if
you